[موسيقى]
تقف وتونس في الذكر الثاني عشر
الحكم استمروا على قلب رجل واحد ولا
المعارضه واجهتهم
لانها لم توافق الى حد الان على الاقل في
تقديم بديل واضحا او الاتفاق على حل موحد
بينهم في المقابل يتماسك رئيس قيس سعيد
بالسياسات
والعماله في اي مخرج من هذه الازمه
السياسيه والاقتصاديه المتفاخمه وهل يمكن
لاي مبادره ان تنقذ البلاد من حاله
الانسداد اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من
سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
دفعت الازمه المتفاقمه في تونس بالجميع
سلطه ومعارضه الى التسعيدي في المواقف
اقوى حساب المعارضه ومنظمات المدنيه
تونسيه نظمت في الذكر الثاني عشر للثوره
مظاهرات الاحتجاجيه حاسده ضد ما تسميه
تفرد الرئيس قيس سعيد بالسلطه وتهديده
للحقوق والحريات وانتهاك استقلال القضاء
مطالبه برحيله بين الرئيس سعيد يقول ان
البلاد في حاله حرب مع من وصفهم بالخونه
والعملاء
في هذه الاثناء يترقبوا التونسيون بقلق
قرارات او مبادرات عاجله تخرجهم من الازمه
التي تتخبط فيها البلاد للنقاش في المخارج
المطروحه لحل الازمه التي تعيشها تونس
يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستديو الدكتور خالد شوكات رئيس المعهد
العربي للديمقراطيه والوزير السابق من
سوسه الدكتور عدنان منصر رئيس مركز
الدراسات الاستراتيجيه حول المغرب العربي
ومن العاصمه التونسيه الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي صلاح الدين الجوريشي اهلا بهم
جميعا
الازمه السياسيه في تونس معقده خاصه في
سياق الحاله الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه
المترديه وفي وقت تحاول قوى سياسيه ومدنيه
تقديم افكار ومقترحات للخروج من الازمه
يمضي الرئيس سعيد قدما في مسائيه غير
مكترثا لا بالاصوات المناديه برحيله ولا
حتى بتلك المطالبه بتعديل المسار
[موسيقى]
يعيش التونسيون حاله انتظار لقرارات او
مبادرات عاجله تخرج من الازمه غير
المسبوقه التي تتخبط فيها البلاد على
المستويات الدستوريه وسياسيه والاجتماعيه
ثلاثه اطراف تتجه اليها انظار التونسينا
هذه الايام املا في تجاوز تلك الازمه بما
انها انهكت موازنتهم اقتصاديا وعكرت
امسيجتهم سياسيه
جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه
لرئيس قيس سعيد احد تلك الاطراف الثلاثه
هذه الجبهه التي رفعت سقف مطالبها الى
الحد الاقصى وبات تطالب برحيل فوريل سعيد
بسبب ما تعتبره فشلا سريعا في سياساته جرى
استفراده بالسلطه وانقلابه على كل المكاسب
الدستوريه التي حققتها البلاد منذ الثوره
كما تقول
حلوا الازمه كما تقترحه الجبهه هو ان
يتسلى السلطه بديلا عن سعيد كاظم من ذوي
الخبره والنزاهه لفتره مؤقته يتولى خلالها
استرجاع المؤسسات الدستوريه واجراء
انتخابات برلمانيه ورئاسيه مع اعتبار
دستور عام 2014 المرجعه وليست الدستور
الذي اقره سعيد في شهر يوليو الماضي
الطرف الثاني الذي تتجه اليه الانظار هو
الاتحاد العام التونسي لشغل الذي اعلن
شروعه في اعداد مبادره لانقاذ ضمت الرابطه
التونسيه للدفاع عن حقوق الانسان وعماده
المحامين التونسيين في انتظار التحاق
هيئات اخرى غير ان هذه المبادره التي وصفت
بانها مبادره للقاضي الاجتماعيه
بعد وان برزت بعض الاختلافات بشانها في
تصريحات قياديين بالاتحاد بين من قال ان
هذه المبادره لن تشمل من يعتبر قرارات
الخامس والعشرين مليون قيلبا في اشاره الى
جبهه الخلاص ومن يوافقها من الاحزاب
الاخرى وبين من قال انها ستتوجه الى
الاحزاب في مرحله لاحقه مع التاكيد على
انها لن تكون شبيهه بالحوار الوطني الذي
شهدته تونس عام 2013
المبادره سيتم تقديمها الى رئيس الدوله
ليست بديلا عن مسار الخامس والعشرين من
يوليو كما صرح عميد المحامين احد مهندسي
هذه المبادره المنتظره الطرف الثالث الذي
ينتظر التونسيون قراراته ومبادراته عساها
تقود الى تجاوز الازمه هو الرئيس قيس سعيد
باعتباره جمع كل سلطات بيده واصبح يسير
البلاد بالمراسيم كما يؤكد معرضه لم
يتفاعل الرئيس قيس سعيد مع اي من
المبادرتين المذكورتين ففي الجانب السياسي
يعتبروا معارضيه خونه وعملاء يفتعلون
الازمات على المستوين السياسي والاجتماعي
بتحالفهم مع المحتكرين والتسبب في ازمه
بالاسواق
كما انه لم يبدي اي موقف من مبادره
المنظمات الاجتماعيه المذكوره ما اضعف
حظوظها قبل اعلنها لانه لا معنى لاي
مبادره ما لم يتفاعل معها رئيس الدوله
وحكمته لتسيد قراراتها على ارض الواقع
مبادره لم تتضح معالمها بدقه بعد
وانتظارات تتعمق من يوم الى اخر وبين هذه
وتلك يبدو نسقوا مطالب الشارع التونسي
اسرع بكثير كما يتجلى ذلك في نداءات
الاستغاثه المتكرره من المواطنين لتوفير
المواد الاساسيه في الاسواق وانقاذ فئات
اجتماعيه بدا يتهددها الفقر جرار استفعال
الازمه التي تصر رئاسه الجمهوريه على
اعتبارهم مفتعله في الوقت الذي يتوضا فيه
اغلب المواطنين بنارها لطفي حجي الجزيره
تونس
وفي ما يلي نستعرض ابرز قرارات الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد هذه القرارات اعتبرها
سعيد مقاربه تاريخيه جديده للبلاد في حين
عددها المعارضه تكريسا لحكم فردي
استبداديه
[موسيقى]
دكتور خالد شوقي اهلا وسهلا بك اهلا وسهلا
ومرحبا التشخيص الازمه في تونس تقريبا
يكاد يكون محل الاجماع تقريبا الملامح
العامه ولكن حين الحديث عن حل معين او
مخرج معين الصوره غير واضحه كيف نفسر ذلك
في اعتقادي ان المعارضه التونسيه اييه رغم
كل المؤاخذات التي تقال هنا وهناك لكن
اداؤها بالقياس الى المده الزمنيه
المحدوده بالمعنى التاريخي يعني سنه ونصف
ليست مده طويله اداءها يعتبر الى حد كبير
مشرفا بالمعنى
الديمقراطي لانه هناك وحده في التشخيص على
الاقل القوه الديمقراطيه القوات السياسيه
القوه المدنيه همم المعتبره التي يعتدوا
بها جميعها تقريبا له نفس الموقف والدليل
انها اغادت رئيس الجمهوريه اكثر من مره هو
خرج لكي يوجهها اتهاماته ونقده للمعارضه
في جميع المداخلات
النهاريه والليليه التي قام بها والتي
استغرب فيها وحده الاوس
والخزرج كما قال في اخر همم مداخله وهو ما
يعني ان وحده المعارضه في اا جزء على قل
التشخيص في جزء ادانتها ل- اا ما وقع
واعتباره خروجا على الشرعيه الدستوريه
والشرعيه القانونيه والشرعيه السياسيه
والشرعيه الاخلاقيه همم كل ذلك ملحوظ
المبادرات متعدده خاصه تسارعت في الفتره
الاخيره واعتقادي انه هناك اشارات تقريبا
لدى جميع اصحاب هذه المبادره
بضروره توحيد الجهود وتوحيد ال- ال- القوه
وتقديري ان هذا الامر يستغرق بعض الوقت
لانه لا يجب ان ننسى ان هذه المعارضه تاتي
من عائله سياسيه مختلفه ذات مرجعيات
سياسيه مختلفه همم كما هو موجود في جل
البلدان العالم العربي والعالم بشكل عام
هذه المبادرات للمعارضه للقوه السياسيه
المختلفه اليها
بالتفصيل حتى نفكها ولكن همم التشخيص هذا
لم يقف فقط عند المعارضه هنا نسال همم سيد
عدنان منصر همم انه حتى بعض القوى
السياسيه او معظمها الان المؤيده للرئيس
او التي كانت مؤيده نراها في الفتره
الماضيه اصبحت هي ايضا ناقده كيف تفسر ذلك
مساء الخير مساء الخير
بان همم
رئيس الجمهوريه همم سعيد الذي يحتكر كل
السلطات همم منذ 25 جبيليا 2021 همم لم
يترك اي فضاء لاي قوى اخرى همم الى جانبه
او همم همم تكون شريكه له وهو رافض اي
حوار واي التقامه اي قوى سياسيه اخرى وهذا
يؤدي الى احساس كل القواسيا تقريبا همم
بان قيس سعيد في اتجاهه لوضع النظام
يستغني عن كل الاحزاب وعن كل التنظيمات
الوسيطه والهياك والاجسام الوسيطه
وبالتالي همم يعني تاكدت في نهايه الامر
حتى تلك التي كانت يعني يعني تشك في في
توجه قيس سعيد تاكدت من انها همم من ان
قيس سعيد همم لن يترك ما كان لاحد وانا
استفراده بالسلطه هو استفراد نهائي وكلي
وتام ولا يقبل الاستثناءات وانه يتجاهل
الى وضع النظام همم همم يعني همم
وهيكله اعاده هيكله الدوله والنظام
السياسي
بطريقه وحتى الاقتصادي بطريقه فرديه
وبطريقه فيها الكثير من الاستبداد والتعسف
والكثير من سوء الفهم لوضع البلاد
بالاضافه بدعه الحيه لما اذق الكبير الذي
تعيش هو البلاد الان نحن لا نتحللنا نتحدث
عن انسداد السياسي فقط ازمه سياسيه فقط
نحن نتحدث عن كارثه اقتصاديه وكارثه ماليه
الدوله الان ليست لها الامكانيات
للانفاق بحسب الميزانيه التي وضعتها
بنفسها همم لهذه السنه وبالتالي همم
الوضع همم يغفر على الجميع حقيقه ان يعيد
النظر حتى اولئك الذين كانوا همم يعني
ينظرون باقل حده لقيس سعيد ولي برنامجه
همم هذه القوه اصبحت مجبره على النظر الى
الواقعه وهو واقع سيء ووقع همم كيري همم
[موسيقى]
النظر هذه التي تتحدث عنها همم نسال عنها
سيد صلاح الدين الجورجي هل ترى اعاده
النظر هذه
تسير بشكل يجعل من الممكن
الالتقاء بشكل يشبه الاجماع على تشخيص
الازمه الحاليه سياسيا واقتصاديا
شوف يعني اذا القينا نظرا موضوعيه عما
يحدث خلال الفتره الاخيره
نلاحظ بانه من جهه رئيس الجمهوريه يعزل
نفسه بشكل مكثف وبشكل متوسط وبالتالي
الاطراف المحيطه حوله لم تعد قادره على ان
تدافع عن هذا التوجه وبدات تتخذ مسافه من
رئيس الجمهوريه في المقابل هذا الرئيس
بالاجراءات التي يتخذها دفع اطراف
المعارضه اللي بينتها تناقضات كثيره
يدفعها الى نوع من التوحد او الوحده بمعنى
انه يدفعها الى ان تضع يدها بيده بيد بعض
وان تلتقي على الاقل على مستوى التشخيص
العام وكذلك على مستوى الشعيرات المركزيه
وهي تقترب ايضا على مستوى الهدف النهائي
لان الدعوه الى همم ازاحه رئيس الجمهوريه
عن السلطه او على الاقل تقليد صلاحيته همم
هذه فحتى تقريبا قاسم مشترك وبالتالي بقدر
ما هناك الديناميكيه من قبل المعارضه
والمخاصمين لرئيس الجمهوريه يتجهون الى
بحث او ايجاد ارضيه مشتركه همم فان رئيس
الجمهوريه
يساعدهم على ذلك وفي نفس الوقت هي
التجاعيد خلف ايات جاء الى الاحتماء بنفس
الصلابه وبنفس الاصرار الذي بدا به لذلك
اصبحت الازمه السياسيه الان في تونس ازمه
تتشاوز الاطراف والاشخاص لتصبح ازمه
هيكليه وتصبح مثال للبحث والدراسه من قبل
جميع الاطراف المختصين في العلوم السياسيه
لما قاله الان السيد صلاح الدين الجرشي
بانه لم يعد هناك من هو قادر للدفاع عن
الرئيس بصراحه هو نحن نعد هذا البرنامج
حاولنا ان يكون معنا ضيف همم عميق قادر
على اضافه فكريه محترمه وان يكون مؤيدا
للرئيس سعيد
نعثر على ذلك للاسف الشديد ربما يوجد
اشخاص اخرون يمكن ان يشاركوا بطريقتهم
ولكنها طريقه لا يمكن ان تقدم لنا اضافه
في برنامج من هذا القبيل ايضا الجرشي تحدث
عن المعارضه والمشهد التونسي الان افرز
بتطوراتهم مجموعه من القوى والتحالفات
اختلفت في توجهاتها
ومبادراتها لكن اغلبها التقى في مواقف
رافضه لمسار الخامس والعشرين من يوليو
يتموز 2021 واجراءات الرئيس سعيد
لان دعم اجراءات قيس سعيد في البدايه طيف
من الاحزاب والمنظمات الا ان ما يمكن
اعتباره جناح الموالاه حصلت بعد مع الوقت
حتى طالت انتقادته قيس سعيد وتوجهاته من
ابرز القوه التي دعمت سعيد حزب الشعب وحزب
البعثه الاشتراكي وحركه تونس الى الامام
والتيار الشعبي لكنها انتقدته خصوصا بعد
اصداره قانون انتخابيا خاصا بالانتخابات
التشريعيه اما في المعارضه فبرزت ائتلافات
جمعت احزابا وشخصيات بينها جبهه الخالص
الوطني برئاسه احمد نجيب الشابي وتاسست في
مايو 2022 تضم والدتكانات سياسيه واعتبرت
اجراءات سعيد انقلاب على الشرعيه من ابرز
مكوناتها حركه النهضه التي تصدرت في
البرلمان السابق قبل حده من الصعيد اضافه
الى حزب قلب تونس وائتلاف الكرامه كما تضم
وحركه مواطنون ضد الانقلاب واحزاب الاخرى
والشخصيات المستقله ودعت سعيد لتناحي والى
انتخابات مبكرا تشرف عليها خاصيه قضائيه
توافقيه كتله المعارضه اخرى وهي كتله
الاحزاب الاجتماعيه الديمقراطيه وشكلت
خمسه منها ائتلافا هي التيار الديمقراطي
والحزب الجمهوري وحزب التكتل وحزب العمال
والقطب الديمقراطي تتحركوا بموازاه حرك
جبهه الخلاص وتختلف معها لكنهما تلتقيان
في مناهضه توجهات واجراءات سعيد كما دعت
لمقاطعه جماعيه للانتخابات التشريعيه ووضع
خريطه طريق لانقاذ تونس الحزب الدستوري
الحر وتراسه عبير موسى وهو محسوب على نظام
ابن علي ويعرض الجميع بما فيهم قيس سعيد
حذرت رئيسته من الاعتراف باي مؤسسه تنبثق
عن سمته المسار غير الشرعي وما سار
الديكتاتوريه بعيدا عن الاحزاب السياسيه
يعد اتحاد الشغل من اهم القوى المجتمعيه
الاتحاد اي اجراءات الصعيد وسماها مسارا
تصحيحيا لكنه لاحقا رفض المشاركه في
الحوار السياسيه التي دعاله واعتبر
الانتخابات التشريعيه بلا رائحه ولا لون
جمع بعض المنظمات والهيئات الاجتماعيه
لاعداد مبادره انقاذ ضمن خيار ثالث واعلن
القياديون فيه رفض اي حوار مع من يعتبرون
حركه الخامس والعشرين من يوليولابا واصفا
اياهم بالمسؤولين عما سماه عشريه الخراب
يفترق المعارضون لقيس سعيد بينما يدعو امن
عام اتحاد الشغل لما سماه معركه وطنيه
بهدف انقاذ تونس مضيفا ان هناك مجتمع
مدنيا ومنظمه وطنيه تقول للحاكم لا للعبه
بالبلاد
دكتور خالد شوكت لو شارعنا في تفكير مختلف
في الاطروحات فيما يتعلق بالحلول الممكنه
الذين يعرضون الرئيس قيس سعيد ويطالبون
برحيله يطالبون بالعوده الى الشرعيه
الدستوريه الى دستور 2014 والرئيس يقول لا
عوده الى الوراء وجزء كبير من ال ال من
الجمهور التونسي على الاقل كما كما يقال
يرفض اي عوده لما كان عليه المشهد اذا
الذين يطالبون بالعوده الى الشرعيه
الدستوريه والقانونيه السابقه هل يبدو هذا
المطلب
قابله للتنفيذ
داني ووضح قليلا للمشاهد العربي خاصه
الخلاف الاكبر الذي تبلوا راه خلال الفتره
الماضيه منذ نفذ
الرئيس سعيد انقلابه على مسار الانتقال
الديمقراطي وجهه النظر الديمقراطيه كانت
معترفه بوجودي مجموعه من القضايا والملفات
والمشاكل والهينات التي يجب معالجتها
والقاعده الديمقراطيه تقول ان الديمقراطيه
هي النظام السياسي الوحيد الذي يستطيع ان
يصحح نفسه من نفسه كالصابون يغسل نفسه
بنفسه ويمكن همم
الموضوع في نقطتين اساسيتين تقريبا في في
افك 25 جويليه كانت بلوره او بسداد بلور
حولها مجموعه من الاراء الموحده همم
الازمه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وضروره منح
التنميه الاول لانه مشكله الديمقراطيه
الناشئه او الواعده في تونس كانت مشكله
تنمويه بالدرجه الاولى وكما يعرف الجميع
الديمقراطيه التي لا تنتج تنميه تظل في
مشكل تظل غير مقنعه لمواطنيها لعموم
مواطنيها يعني جزء كبير من رد فعل
التونسيين على مسار الانتقال الديمقراطي
هو عجز المرحله الانتقاليه على تغيير
واقعهم الاقتصادي والاجتماعي والاستجابه
الانتظاراتهم
التنمويه هذا من جهه ومن جهه اخرى كان
هناك وعي بانه لا يمكن اصلاح او لا يمكن
اطلاق الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
الا باصلاحات دستوريه على دستوري الثوره
دستور 2014 وكان بمقدورنا ان نحدث مجموعه
من الاصلاحات على هذا الدستور المرجيعي
على هذا النص الدستوري الذي اشاد به خبراء
القانون الدستوري في العالم ككل كوثيقه
ذات اهميه وصيغه بطريقه تشاركيه وشاركت
فيها جميع التيارات الفكريه والسياسيه كم
بالامكان هناك همم هناك ظهرت من خلال
التطبيق ومثل ما حدث في التجارب المقارنه
التجارب الاخرى نحن لم نخترع الانتقال
الديمقراطي فكان بالامكان احداث اصلاحات
دستوريه همم تجعل النظام السياسي اكثر
انسجاما واكثر ديناميكي واكثر همم فاعليه
فهذين الحزمتين كان بالامكان احداثهما من
خلال
الاطار الديمقراطي من خلال النظام
الديمقراطي باصلاحات الدستوريه وقانونيه
وبمراجعات في السياسات الحكوميه همم
استغلت الازمه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
استغلت انه استلجيا اي الحنين حنين الشعوب
وهذه ظاهره تدخل في علم نفس الجماهير
معروفه يعني الجماهير في مراحل الانتقال
الديمقراطي عاده ما تحن الى الانظمه
الاستبداديه بكل ما تعنيه من رئاساويه
تسلطيه فرديه همم يتصورون او يتهيا لهم
انه مثل هذه الانظمه هي سريعه في اتخاذ
القرارات وستعالج مشاكلهم الاقتصاديه الى
غير ذلك هذه البيئه مهدت لي وقف مسار
الانتقال الديمقراطي بناء على مجموعه من
الاساطير والاوهام التي اكتشف جل
التونسيون خلال سنه ونصف تقريبا انها مجرد
اوهام واساطير وان النظام الرئاسه والفردي
التسلطي الذي اقر بالدستور الجديد لن يفلح
لا في معالجه الازمه الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه ولا في تحقيق اي همم تقدم في
اي ملف مطروح على البلاد ولكن كل الذين
يتحدثون عن العوده الى الشرعيه الدكتور
عدنان منصر عاده همم يقال لهم انكم تريدون
بنا ان نعود الى نفس المشهد السياسي وي
بان في هذه الحاله اذا عدنا للدستور 2014
الى الشرعيه
فسنجد شخص راشد الغنوشي رئيس البرلمان هو
الرئيس المؤقت للبلاد لمده شهرين حتى
انتخاب رئيس جديد وبالتالي هذا لا نقبله
كيف يمكن ان نشرح ان العوده الى الشرعيه
الدستوريه والى المؤسسات ورفض ما يوصف
بالانقلاب من قبل قيس سعيد لا يعني
بالضروره ان يعود نفس الشخوص ونفس المشهد
السياسي السابق
بطبيعه حاله هذا الكلام الكلام يقال في
اطار الرد رد انصار الرئيس على محاولات
ايجاد مخرج هذه الازمه بطبيعه الحال هناك
يعني
كثير من السيارات الممكنه والكثير من
الحلول لهذه القضيه
بالتاكيد هناك يعني
تصورات تنتقل من
او تنطلق من فكره مرحله انتقاليه
قصيره تتلوها انتخابات ليس بشرط هذه
الانتخابات ان تصفر عن نفس المشهد السياسي
القديم وبالتالي هذا كلام همم يعني يردوا
عليه لانه همم الاكيد هو ان الدستور قيس
سعيد ليس فيه مخرج في هذه الاسماء والاكيد
لانه اذا اردنا ان نبحث عن مخارج هذه
الازمه همم لم نعرف عليها في كل النصوص
التي اصدرها الصعيد همم لذلك يتراوح
المبادلات الان بين توجهين اساسيين
يدعو الى رحيل الرئيس تماما وتوجه يدعو
الى
اجباره او تخليه عن كل سلطاته المطلقه
والتحويل هذه السلطات الى حكومه
قادره على اتخاذ اجراءات في اطار مرحله
انتقاليه وهي تقريبا نفس نفس المقاله
الاوروبيون الامريكان في في شهر اشبيليهود
من سنه 2021 يعني كل المبادلات تنطلق من
من هذين
التصورين الاساسيين لكن اكيد هو انه همم
همم حتى بالعوده الى دستور 2014 الاكيد ان
هناك هناك في هذا الدستور لان هذا الدستور
كانت بطريقه اخرى وهذه مشكله كبيره كان
نوعا من الدستور المغلق وكان نوع من
الدستور المفرغ للازمات واكبر همم يعني
همم ازمه ادى اليها للدستور والتصادم
المستمر بين راسي التنفيذيه فالاكيد ان
هذا الدستور يحتاج الى مراجعه ولكن في كل
الحالات لا يمكن العثور على اي حل من حلول
اي ازمه تمر بها اليوم فيما انتجه قيس
سعيد من نصوص في ذلك دستور همم يعني
2022 نعم الذين يطالبون برحيل للرئيس سيد
صلاح الدين لجورجي هل تراه
مطلبا قابلا للتنفيذ لان الرجل مثلما
راينا لا يعبى بهؤلاء ماضي في سياساته
وبالتالي عندما نتحدث عن رحيل رحيل كيف
يعني اذا استبعدنا اي طريقه فيها عنف او
طريقه فيها تدخل للعسكر ورئيس يرفض
الاستقاله او او المغادره اذن الرحيل كيف
يمكن ان يكون
هو الحقيقه هذا هو السؤال اللي لا تستطيع
المعارضه الان ان تجيب عنه بشكل واضح
ودقيق لماذا لانه ما اقترحاته جبهه الخلاص
هو يقتضي قبل ذلك توفر شرط وهذا شرط هو
حصول شهور في المستوى رئاسه الجمهوريه
ولكن كيف سيحصل هذا الشعور كيف سيقعاد قيس
سعيد عن رئاسه الجمهوريه وعن قصر القرطاج
هذا السؤال لا يقع الاجابه عنه بكل وضوح
لماذا لان اللعبه الان في تونس لعبه مغلقه
يعني نحن في تونس خرجنا من ازمه سابقه همم
دستوريه وسياسيه حيث ان ما سمي بنظام
الرؤساء الثلاث همم اصطدموا مع بعض ولم
تستطع البلاد انها تخرج بشكل توافقيا او
بشكل شرعي من تلك الازمه ولكن وجدنا
انفسنا في ازمه اخرى قائمه على حكم فردي
همم رئيس الجمهوريه كل الصلاحيات ولان
المعارضه بشكل عام معارضه تؤمن بالقانون
وتستند على القانون ولا تريد ان تلجا الى
وسائل العنف ولا تريد انها تستدرج
المؤسسات الصلبه الى ان تلعب دور لن نرفضه
في تونس ولا نريده لتونس ولذلك بقي الجميع
يطالبون يفكرون ولكن في داخلي الاطار
المغلق لان كل ما التفت على يمين او شمالا
الا ووجدت بان هناك دائره ولا يوجد في
داخل هذه الدائره طريق يؤدي بكاء خروجه
همم منها ولعل الفكره هي التي بعد وكاننا
يجب ان ننتظر 2014 لكي نقيم انتخابات همم
عفوا 2024 لكي ننظم انتخابات سلميه
وقانونيه ولكن من هنا الى 2014 هل سيثبت
النظام الاقتصادي هل سيصمد النظام السياسي
هل سيستقبل تونسي تقبل التونسي هذا الوضع
الذي يزداد تعفنا يوما بعد يوم
اصلاح متمسك بال 2014
رئاسيه في 2024 وهناك من قال بهذا الراي
وهناك من قال لا نريد انتخابات رئاسيه
سابقه لاوانها مثلا سيد فاضل عبد الكافي
ترى هذا الامر ولكن هناك ثغره في طرح سيد
فاضل عبد الكافي وهو وزير سابق ورئيس حزب
الافاق تونس يقول تجري انتخابات رئاسيه
سابقه لاوانها بناءا على هذا الدستور ثم
من ينجح في هذه الانتخابات يذهب في
تعديلات في هذه الحاله الذين يقولون ما
بني على باطل فهو باطل لا لا مكان له هنا
يعني هل يمكن البحث عن حل بالاعتماد على
ما فرضه ليس سعيد والاستناد اليه هذه ايضا
اشكاليه الاصل في الشيء هو انه ما لا
ينظمه القانون او ينظمه الدستور
في سياق الديمقراطي تنظمه الاعراف لانه
الديمقراطيه هي ايضا مجموعه من الاعراف
مجموعه من الخبرات مجموعه من التجارب واهم
مبدا يقوم عليه النظام الديمقراطي هو مبدا
السياده الشعبيه بمعنى ان الشعب هو الذي
يحكم وبماذا يحكم الشعب بالاساس بالدرجه
الاولى يحكم من خلال الانتخابات من خلال
التعبير عن ارادته في انتخابات الحره
ونزيهه واديمقراطيه و ضمن المعايير
المنصوص عليها دوليا او المتعارف عليها
دوليا وكان يفترض بالحاكم العادي الطبيعي
عندما تتازم الامور والحاكم العادي
الطبيعي هو همم حاكم لا يعاند يعني عندما
تلوح الازمه والازمه الان بابعاد متعدده
ليست ازمه سياسيه فقط ولكن ازمه اقتصاديه
واجتماعيه نحن نعرف مثلا من خلال النموذج
اليوناني على سبيل المثال وفي غمره وفي
قلب الازمه السياسيه ازمه المديونيه الى
غير ذلك وحزب فاز منذ هو فقط لواء حزب
سيريزا وعاد الى ال- ال- ال- الشعب عاد
الى الشعب ل لان الموقف يستدعي العوده الى
الشعب ولان المسؤوليه تقتضي اشراكه الشعب
اا للاسف الشديد لا يبدو ان الرئيس مثل ما
هو قد اغلق اذنيه تجاه النخب السياسيه
بحجه القضاء على همم الاجسام الوسيطه وهذه
ممارسه ايضا غريبه عجيبه همم وفريده من
نوعها في التاريخ وفي الجغرافيا
هو يقول انا انا انا نظمت استشاره
وصوت على الدستور اكثر من مليونين ونصف او
شيء من هذا القبيل
وذهبوا في انتخابات دور اول انتخابات
برلمانيه
والدوره الثانيه في نهايه هذا الشهر
وبالتالي انا في مسار
وفيه انخرارات شكرا على هذا السؤال ذكرتنا
يعني العوده الى الشعب ايضا
يجب ان تحدث ضمن الاعراف والمعايير وهمم
وشروط همم المتعارف عليها ايضا دوليا فهل
يعقل ان يتم اقرار دستور كتب بطريقه فرديه
بثلاثين بالمائه فقط من الناخبين يعني
عمليا عندما يتعلق الامر بوثيقه الدستوريه
عاده ما يشترط ان يكون هناك ثلثان من
الناخبين وافقوا على الثلثاء من المسجلين
يعني ومن يحق لهم الانتخاب وافقوا لانه
الدستور هو وثيقه يفترض انها تاريخيه
وستبقى طويلا وليست مثل القوانين الاساسيه
او القوانين العاديه قبل ذلك نظم استشاره
ورغم بقائها استشاره الكترونيه ورغم
بقائها اكثر من شهرين ولكن كم شارك فيها
من التونسي 6% وفي الانتخابات الاخيره
حققنا الرقم القياسي همم ودعنا من الجعجع
اللفظيه ومن الهروب من خلال همم يعني همم
توجيه الشتائم والسباب للمعارضين او
للمخالفين في الراي هل يمكن القبول ب
8.8% من الناخبين او حتى 11 مثلما صرحت
هيئه الانتخابات 11% من التونسيين يذهبون
الى همم مراكز الاقتراح ولا يحدث ولا يحدث
شيء ولكن هذا الشوط الاول انتظر الشوط
الثاني ههه يعني وهذا مما يعني يستفز همم
اكثر ما معنى الشوط الثاني معناها همم
سنجمع عدد الذين ذهبوا في الدورتين وهل
سنجمع ايضا عدد الذين امتنعوا في
الدورهتين يعني همم جنرال دي جول في
استفتاء
في الاستفتاء الذي استقال من اجله يعني
كان عنده اغلبيه بسيطه
اعتبرها تلك رساله واضحه من الشعب الفرنسي
تدعوه الى مغادرتي الحكم فما يحدث في تونس
في الحقيقه غير مقبول بمعايير
الديمقراطيات المستقره والمعروف هناك
الدكتور النصر بين
منطقه الرئيس قيس سعيد ومنطق معارضيه ما
سمي بالخيار الثالث وهذا يدفع باتجاهه
اتحاد الشغل البعض يلومه على اساس انه
يضعوا رجلا هنا ورجل هناك ولكنه همم ماض
في بلوره مبادره همم هل تعتقد بان هذا
النوع من التوليفات قادر على انقاذ البلاد
كما يقول الاتحاد
اعتقد انه الاتحاد
يعني فيما اذا ايضا لانه
طالما لا يزال يفكر وهذا هو المنطق في
الحقيقه في كل الحوار وفي كل مبادره طالما
لا يزال يعتقد ان على رئيس الجمهوريه ان
يقبل بهذه المبادره لا يمكن تنفيذها فانه
يعيش في نفس المازق ويراوح في مكانه منذ
يعني
مده طويله منذ بدايات طرح فكره
حوار سياسي مع رئيس جمهوريه او مبادره او
ما الى ذلك هذه هذه ليست يعني مبادره
جديده وليست الفكره جديده ايضا الاتحاد هو
همم
يعيش على وقع همم توازنات سياسيه داخليه
لا يجب ان ننسى ان الكثير من همم قيادات
الاتحاد وفيها اكله المركزيه همم ينتمون
سياسيا او متقاربون سياسيا مع احزاب لها
ااا وجهتنا ضرر مختلفه ومتناقضه فمن
الطبيعي ان يكون الاتحاد
يحاول ان يجمع بين هذه الاراء وبين الواقف
لكن اليوم امام وقعتقد انه مناقشت مساله
شرعيه دستور قيس سعيد او شرعيه استفتائه
او شرعيه كل النصوص التي اصدرها اعتقد
انها اصبحت في عداد الماضي منذ المشاركه
الهزيله في انتخابات 17 صعبه
المازق الحقيقي الان وانا نبي ازاء نظام
لا يستطيع تاسيس شرعيه على المقاييس
الديمقراطيه الليبراليه
وايضا لم ينجز شيئا وان ما همم العيدان
وكفاءات ايه ادت الى غرق البلاد في كارثه
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه وسياسيه وبالتالي همم
الحديث عن او او مجادله الرئيس وانصاره في
موضوع الشرعيه
اعتقد انها اصبحت من من كلام الماضي همم
هناك سؤال في الحقيقه الرئيس عندما علق
على نتائج انتخابات اغتصاب قال انه همم
8% او ال11 الذين ذهبوا للتصويت هم افضل
من 99% ها الذين كانوا يصودون في السابق
اعتقد انه هذا ينبئنا باي
طريقه الصعيد الفعل على انتخابات الرئاسيه
قد لا ينتصر فيها وقد لا يجوز فيها هل
سيقبل بتسليم السلطه اعتقد انه همم هذا
الاشكال يجب ان يفكر فيه الناس من الان
نظره رئيس الجمهوريه الديمقراطيه نظره
مناطق تماما
للقيام الديمقراطيه المتعارف عليها واعتقد
انه همم همم ما يقال في في سياق همم
امكانيه اقناع الرئيس همم
باي مبادرات او اي اصلاحات همم يعني همم
يؤدي الى تنازله عن بعض السلطاته او الى
رحيله اعتقد ان هذا همم اصبح من قبيل
العبث السياسي واعتقد انه هذا سيجعل كل
المبادرات تفشل طالما انه هذه المبادرات
لا تاخذ بعين الاعتبار ال ال المكونات
الحقيقيه للازمه ومن بين هذه المكونات
شخصيه سعيد ونفسيته وطريقه تعامله همم هل
ترى سيد جورج بان فعلا هذه المبادره محكوم
عليها بالفشل ليس فقط لعدم تفاعل الرئيس
ولكن ايضا لان اصحابها يقولون لا نتحاور
مع من يعتبر 25 يوليو انقلاب وبالتالي فهم
ايضا انتقائيون في البحث عن الحوار وعن
انجاح المبادره
يضاف الى ذلك ان مبادره الاتحاد التي لا
ارى لها مستقبل واضحا هو
انها تعتمد في الاساس على ان تتحرك داخل
الدائره التي وضعها الرئيس قيس سعيد اي
داخل المنظور وداخل الاليات التي يتصرف
فيها سعيد بشكل كامل وهم بسبب اعداد هذه
المبادره والكثير منهم يعلمون مسبقا بان
الرئيس لن يستجيب لهذه المبادله او هناك
شكوك كبيره في انه في همم يستفيد خاصه وان
ان هم حيث
يحاولوازنه بين الجانب الاجتماعي
والاقتصادي في مطالبهم ولكن ايضا سيتعرضون
للجانب السياسي والجانسي سيطلبون من
الرئيس انهم يتخلى عن بعض صلاحياته ان
يعطي صلاحيات اكثر للحكومه وان يشكل حكومه
اما اقتصاديه او سياسيه لكنها تتمتع بحق
المبادره وهذا يعني بان النظريه التي
حولها الى سياسه رئيس الجمهوريه همم فشلت
اي ان يكون هو الذي يملك وهو الذي يوجه
والبقيه يتصرفون وفق همم نصائحه وفق
التوجيهاتك الرئيس فشل وعلى الاتحاد قالها
في اكثر من المناسبات بان الرئيس غير قادر
على ان يدير شؤون الدوله بهذه الطريقه
وبالتالي كيف يمكن للرئيس سعيد انه يتراجع
الى الخلف هو بين بوضوح وبشكل قطعيه بانه
غير متعدد ان يعترف بالفشل او ان يقوم
بخطوات نحو الوراء وبالتالي ان يعيد
تسليما زمام او جزء من صلاحيته وزمام
الامور بي دي اطراف اخرى حتى لو قيل له
بانها ست تساعده على انجازه مشروعيه اذا
اعتقد بان مبادره الاتحاد والمجتمع المدني
الذي سيلتفه حوله ستكون النقطه للنسف عذره
للاهمال والاسقاط من قبل الرئيس نفسه نعم
سنقوم في نهايه هذه الحلقه بجوله بين
ضيوفنا الثلاثه كل ضيف يسعى الى ان يقدم
تصوره لسيناريو المتوقع في الفتره المقبله
في تونس في ضوء ما نقشناه لحد الان والذي
للاسف يعكس نوع من حاله انسداد نبدا بسيد
الجوشي ثم الدكتور النصر ثم ننهي بدكتور
خالد شوكت هنا في سوريا تفضل سيد جورج
هو هو الحقيقه اسالتك كلها قابله باننا
نتفاعل معها الا هذا السؤال صعب جدا
الحقيقه لانه لحد الان في داخل
الفضاء التونسي يصعب التكهن
بالمالات المقال سيكون صعبا وانما اخشاها
ان يكون مؤلما وان يكون خارج الاعراف
وخارج
التقاليد الديمقراطيه همم السلميه لان
البلد الان في حاله حيره كبيره التونسيون
يبحثون عن اكسجين حتى يجددون شويه تنفس
وينقذون انفسهم من الاختناق الكامل وبذلك
وفي المقابل الرئيس يرفض الاستماع ويرفض
التعامل بشكل موضوعي للواقع لكن اعتقد
بانه ربما في لحظه من اللحظات وهنا اعمل
عمليه فرضيه شبه خياليه افترض بان بعض
الناس سيبادرون سيطلبون من رئيس الجمهوريه
وهم يتمتعون بنوع من الحكمه ونوع من
الرساله ونوع من الاستقلاليه يتوجهون
الجمهوريه لكي يحاولنا الاقناعه وزحزحه
مواقفه قليلا الى ان نصل الى
2024 قد يقبل ولكن الاغلب ظن انه لن يقبل
وبالتالي ليس لدي جواب قطعي وواضح عن
سؤالكم الهام سيد محمد كريشان شكرا لك
دكتور منصر
واعتقد اا
من تاريخ
الحكم في تونس همم منذ يعني قبل الثوره
وربما الان هو انه لا احد من امسك بكل
السلطات رحله بمشيئته يعني انه همم يقبل
في التخفيض من صلاحياته او من شروطاته هذا
لم يحصل ابدا وحتى محاوله الاصلاح اللي
تمت في عهد بن علي او في عهد همم برجيبه
كانت محاوله اصلاح سرعان ما تم الالتفاف
عليها انا اتوقع حقيقه في ظل هذا الانسداد
همم وفي ظل تصاعد همم الازمه ان يزداد
تعفن المراه همم بطريقه همم تصبح فيها
مؤسسه الدوله
عازه عن العمل وعن مواجهه لدعايه هذه
الازمه عند اذن سيحصل تقارب همم وهذا
تقليدي في تاريخ تونس من اجل الاعداد
لعمليه همم مرحله انتقاليه همم سلميه همم
مرحله انتقاليه في تاريخنا همم يعني كانت
دائما عندما تصل الامور الى الى مثل هذه
النقطه همم
يلتقي الفرقاء همم يلتقون داخل همم حدود
المؤسسات وداخل حدود القوانين وداخل حدود
الدستوريه وعندما اقول حدود الدستوريه انا
اتحدث عن دستور 2014
ايجاد حلول همم الحلول الاقل كلفه همم
ممكن ممكنه نعم دكتور شوكات هو نحن لماذا
كنا متمسكين ولا نزال بالنظام الديمقراطي
حتى في صيغه الانتقاليه حتى لا نجيبها على
مثل هذه الاسئله لانه في الانظمه
الديمقراطيه لا تطرح مثل هذه الاسئله
والحاكم في الغالب همم يعني طريقته خروجه
عاده ما تكون حضاريه وسلميه ويذهب الى
التقاعد المريح الى غير ذلك ليست وزراء
نيوزيلندا اليوم
منحى الامم المتحضره همم والديمقراطيات
المستقره حتى تكون الخواتيم همم لحكامنا
خواتيم انسيابيه واا سلميه ومدنيه الى غير
ذلك لكن للاسف الشديد اعدتنا الاحداث من
لعلنا ناخذ العبره منها لانه اهم عبره
سياخذها التونسيون انه النظام الديمقراطي
هو الافضل والاحسن في ترتيب مثل هذه
المسائل مع ذلك اريد ان اقول بان المعارضه
الديمقراطيه المعارضه في تونس هي معارضه
الديمقراطيه ومدنيه وسلميه وحريصه على ان
يظل الطابع السلمي المدني المتحضر هو الذي
يوجهها في سلوكها
في بلادنا ولله الحمد همم ليس لدينا
تقاليد في الفتن وفي الحروب الاهليه وفي
الاقتتال الداخلي لغير ذلك الشعب التونسي
لديه في المجال السياسي تقاليد ايضا سلميه
ومتحضره وفي الاخير يصل التونسيون الى
الحافه لكنهم غالبا ما يجدون مخرجا لائقا
يحافظ على مكتسباتهم ويعالج ازماتتهم
لو كان الوضع الاقتصادي والاجتماعي عادي
هناك من يشعر الان بالخوف من ثوره همم
اجتماعيه ثوره جياح همم الان اصبحت تونس
تتلقى مساعدات بالشاحنات من ليبيا وهذا
المشهد يعني لم تشهده تونس عبر تاريخها مع
كل الاحترام للشعب الليبي ان ترسل 100
شاحنه مساعدات غذائيه لتونس هذا امر غير
مسموح هناك من يقول باننا نخشى من ثوره
جياع بدون شعارات سياسيه بدون قياده وهذه
قد تجر البلاد لا سمح الله لما الات صعبه
جدا وهذه الخش هي عاده مساء ما تدفع همم
مختلف في الاطراف والقوه سواء داخل الدوله
ومؤسسات الدوله او في المجتمع السياسي او
في المجتمع المدني للالتقاء وايجاد حل
واهم مؤشرات رحيل اي حاكم هي اداءه
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي وفشله في معالجه
الملفات الكبرى ودفعه بلاده الى شفيري
الهاويه لقدر الله في كل الاحوال انا
متفائل بان التونسيين لديهم القدره والنخب
التونسيه لديها من الحكمه بحيث تجد حلا
حضاريا يعيد المسار الديمقراطي الى سياقه
الطبيعي شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور خالد شوكت
رئيس المعهد العربي الذيمقراطيه والوزير
السابق شكرا لحضورك شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من
سوسه الدكتور عدنان منصر رئيس مركز دراسات
الاستراتيجيه حول المغرب العربي شكرا لك
ايضا من تونس العاصمه الكاتب والمحل
السياسي التونسي
صلاح الدين الجوشي وطالم ان الحلقه همم هي
عن تونس نذكر مره اخرى بان مكتبنا في
العاصمه التونسيه ما زال مغلقا الى حد
الان منذ قامه الرئيس قيس سعيد باجراءاته
في الخامس والعشرين من يوليو عام 2021
مكتب مغلق بدون قرار قضائي بدون قرار
اداري لا احد يعلم من اتخذ القرار وكيف
والى من يمكن اللجوء للطعن فيه همم كل
فريق الجزيره في تونس يعملون في المقاهي
يعملون في الشارع او في بيوتهم مع انه
لديهم كل التراخيص القانونيه الممكنه
للعمل كحافيين وحضور المؤتمرات الصحفيه
وغيره ولكن المكتب مغلق وهو المكتب الوحيد
المغلق بدون من همم تسبب دون معرفه من
تسبب او بالاحرى دون الاشاره اليه بال-
بالاصبعه همم بشكل همم مباشر مره اخرى
معالجه هذا الامر وان يعود مكتبنا للعمل
وان يكون ضيوفنا في الاستديو مكتبنا في
تونس العاصمه وليس في بيوتهم شكرا لكم
مشاهدينا الكرام والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[موسيقى]